my name is Roberta I'm the director of
the institute for the study of European
columbia university and i would like to
welcome all of you must copy also in the
name of my colleagues especially the
director of the heroin institute with
whom we are doing this together and also
my colleagues John midscale and Kevin
Harlan who have been very much involved
in the organization of this and i would
like to welcome of course especially our
foreign guests who've come from afar and
i hope they are not too jet-lagged
because we will have i'm sure to very
interesting days of lively discussion
and presentations let me just explain
what i suggest it might be the procedure
for this first session i would like to
say a few words of introduction just to
tell you about the considerations behind
this particular meeting and then i would
like to ask ambassador blinken to say a
few words relating also to our keynote
speaker he knows well and then i would
like to introduce the keynote speaker
and if there is then time for discussion
at the end of his lecture and i'm sorry
that we started late into the microphone
also has erupted yet so it's the usual
problems early in the morning in this
institution but at any rate if there's
time I hope there will be some questions
which professor Gotti will take
otherwise we will have to
proceed to the next panel straight away
and then we have of course the afternoon
also now to give you some background
information about this there are of
course many meetings taking place also
in this town this last week and this
week again remembering and commemorating
the events in east-central europe in
1956 exactly 50 years ago but while
these are I think meetings where there
is a lot of commemoration we thought it
would be good in this institution to
have the very firmly academic event also
and that is why we thought also it would
be a good idea to take a more
comprehensive view of the upheavals that
happened 50 years ago in that part of
Europe and we felt that it would be
appropriate therefore to start our first
panel with the crush of speech and its
impact and then and that is also an
intention not to keep the polish events
and the Hungarian events totally
separate which tends to happen quite
frequently these days rather to see
whether them we can also establish an
intellectual academic dialogue between
all the experts who are here and some of
them will know each other already but I
have a feeling that some others will
meet for the first time and my hope is
that indeed there will be further
contact coming out of this conference
both in east-central europe but also
across the Atlantic so that was one
consideration and the other one was that
we really also wanted to look not just
at the latest research that is now being
produced and a lot of it was not
available to many of us who do not
polish or russian or Hungarian so that
we would learn about the latest research
that we were also hoping to look at the
long-term fall out the implications of
these events 50 years ago and that is
why we have this composition of panels
on each panel we do have also people who
will be looking at the consequences of
what happened and then as you will have
noticed also we thought it would be very
important to try to put the whole these
events into a global context at the end
of it and that is why we have tomorrow
afternoon the final session and we are
very glad that we persuaded professor
port jervis to introduce this because
I'm hoping that so this will also open
up all sorts of major questions which
are of the other transnational nature to
look back on these events so I hope you
can see why we are really looking
forward to two days of good discussion
lively discussion and exchanges now it's
a great honor for me and a pleasure to
introduce ambassador Donald Lincoln who
has of course as a New Yorker many
connections both with Western Europe
where he spent many years earlier on in
his life but they're also with e Central
Europe he is a member of the board of
trustees of the Central European
University and in fact wanted to be here
this morning although he is flying to
buda-pesht only this evening so I'm
delighted that he's able to come as you
may know he was also ambassador to
Hungary during the Clinton years he is
also and that is what I cannot resist
mentioning also the very loyal and
helpful coach
of our international advisory board of
the institute for the study of Europe
and I know that he's also an IRA or
professor Gotti's work so I will hand
over to him to say a few words by way of
introduction good morning thank you very
much talker I think Columbia is
absolutely the right place to be dealing
with these very very interesting issues
stemming from what happened 50 years ago
there were two at Cold War events i
think that continue to reverberate today
one is the Cuban Missile Crisis the
other obviously the hungarian uprising
in Revolution of 1956 both of them still
attract our attention and we consider
their the results of those those
episodes to be important meeting today
fifty years later than the one case
rusher or the Soviet Union was involved
in both and so I think it's quite
appropriate that the subject of today's
these meetings is the impact of 56
revolution and other events in central
Eastern Europe on what was then the
Soviet Union is a Russia of course my
focus is on hungry where I have a little
bit of expertise not on the rest of
Central Europe or the Soviet Union if
you were living in Hungary or working in
Hungary as i did in the 1990s you could
not but help be aware of the fact that
1956 still hovered like a very faint
cloud over all the events in Hungary it
wasn't fair amount but you knew it was
there be gusting people both in Hungary
and and 56 years of the United States
kept raising the issue what
to government the Socialists and others
would bring to the emerging hungary in
1996 I became aware of in fact that the
radio free europe tapes dealing with the
hungarian uprising and the run-up to it
we're being moved from their air storage
place in in germany to Eastern Europe
the question was where were these tapes
and duh and by chance I got in contact
with Ross Johnson in Washington and the
two of us agreed that the radio for
Europe takes dealing with the Hungarian
episode should belong to the Hungarian
people so we spent about a year trying
to persuade routier for Europe officials
in Washington that these tapes should be
turned over to the Hungarian government
and happily after about a year's work
they were indeed turned over on main
22nd in 1997 I had the honor of speaking
on the occasion the return of the radio
free europe takes to hungary's National
Library the return of the radio for your
capes to Hungary I noted is an
opportunity both to reconsider the past
and think about the future there's also
an opportunity for the Hungarian people
and Hungarian historians to regain a
missing segments of a historical legacy
recently I said I came into possession
of a US government memorandum written on
the rubber twentieth nineteen fifty six
which discusses radio for Europe's role
in the Hungarian Revolution this paper
states that quote from all information
available to date radio for Europe did
not incite the Hungarian people to
revolution and decor 40 years after the
event I concluded an American cannot
comment on the validity of these
observations but I believe that with the
return of it takes to Hungary I'm Gary
and academics journalists and the
Hungarian people at large can examine
the evidence and make up their own minds
that was four years ago we're now 50
years after the event in a lot of a lot
of evidence has been accumulated we know
a great to know more than we do in 1996
about the radio if you give Europe's
role and about the origins of the
Hungarian Uprising what caused it what
actually happened what might have
happened these events I think most
beautifully summed up in Charles
Gandhi's very very moving book failed
illusion that Senator late Senator
Patrick Moynihan sent very famously that
people are entitled their opinions but
they're not entitled to their facts I
think that applies very very well to
Charles Gotti's role as that as a
teacher and a student and a writer he's
very much emotionally involved obviously
and what happened in hungry hungarian
glad to said he left Hungary during the
nineteen fifty-six uprising and he has
strong feelings about it but at the same
time to his credit he's never allowed
those feelings I think to interfere with
his academic scholarship and his
studious observance of the facts as he's
been able to obtain them so I think we
all owe him a debt of gratitude for
producing a book that clarifies what
happened and leads us to certain
possible conclusions one final word
about Charles in addition to being a
wonderful scholar and writer he's also
been a mentor to many American
ambassadors during the past 10 or 15
years I know in my case before going to
Budapest in 1994 I sought him out we had
some talks and he continued to be a very
very important influence and source of
ideas on what was going on with
contemporary hungry and I
he's continued that role with the six of
my success for ambassadors to hungry so
that we all have my second debt of
gratitude for being an important
resource for the United States foreign
service the State Department on what's
happening in hungry in East Europe so
with that I'd like to say Charles was
delighted delightful to have you here
we're looking forward to hearing from
you thank you very ste and has been a
senior adviser on the policy planning
staff of the State Department and he was
also a professor at Union College and
here at Columbia for a while and he has
written of course very extensively on
the events also of our conference and
the larger background to this some of
you will know his book of the block that
failed of 1990 then in 1986 already he
published a book called Hungary and the
Soviet bloc which one the Marshall
Sherman prize for us as an outstanding
book published in the United States on
Soviet foreign policy so he's very
wide-ranging in his work and he is the
co-author or editor of some 16 books
dealing with the Central Europe and the
problems that have preoccupied him in
his scholarship for many years and Don
blinken just mentioned of course his
recently published book failed illusions
which was reviewed as you will have seen
it perhaps in the New York Times Book
Review only last Sunday so we have a
very eminent scholar to introduce this
and I'm really very glad that he we
could persuade him to be here because
only a few days ago he was also in
Europe so I'm delighted and grateful
Charles that you were able to come here
and we look forward to your talk and
hope that there will still be some time
for you to answer some questions also so
thank you for coming
thank you very much extremely kind of
introductions I am grateful to
ambassador blinking for having all that
there was a reception I think just this
past weekend in the White House and I I
was in Moscow where I read in in a
hungarian daly who was invited the white
house to watch a new movie about 1956
and to my horror I saw that a former
leader of the Arrow Cross party in 1944
was also there so I'm definitely not
responsible I've already written a
couple of protests about that but you
know things happen but thanks Donald I
appreciate your good words and thank you
very much for the introduction and for
inviting me here I particularly liked it
because the last few weeks some of us
several people in this audience have
been giving talks about the Hungarian
Revolution of 1956 but usually you don't
have enough time and so you get your 10
minutes or seven minutes or at most 15
minutes at the Council on Foreign
Relations where Bob black volt was the
host I got two minutes at a time or
three maybe once i went beyond he
interrupted me but I forgave him because
he wrote very nicely about my book in
foreign affairs so he got away with it
this time this topic appealed to me
because it is broader that Volker gave
me and the topic is the cold as it
seniors your schedule the cold war in
Europe and the 1956 Hungarian revolt I
had to prepare for this actually unlike
some of the other talks I've given in
recent weeks I have obviously lots of
notes but I don't have to do separate
and special preparations I did have to
do that but before I get to the topic
let me just say that I came from Moscow
yesterday arrived and there is
considerable interest they're not
only in Hungary 1956 but also hungry
2006 they see the situation so bad both
in Hungary and in Russia that there are
now jokes again and I always find that a
good indicator of how things are going
once they have jokes you know that
things are bad so here is one that that
has something to do with both hungry and
Russia that I will read to you this is
supposed to be the text of a telegram
sent by some Hungarians to President
Putin quote when your troops were here
all Hungarians were of one mind stop we
hated you stop we were united stop since
you left we are no longer United stop we
hate each other stop please revoke your
old decision and return immediately stop
you have to be able to laugh about
what's going on well about the cold war
in Europe let me start out with that
obviously and make one start out with
one generalization from the end of World
War two but especially from 1947 until
the death of Stalin I think it is
possible to say with some simplification
that the Cold War was one dimensional it
was a confrontation not necessarily buy
weapons but certainly was an ideological
political economic and potentially
military confrontation it is true that
there was some there were some early
deviations from the to camp situation
which was formalized only barge Donald
and the Truman Doctrine it is true that
in Hungary you had elections in 1945
those were quite free and even in 1947
which
still competitive not not quite free
czechoslovakia in 1946 and of course in
the West the italian and french
communist parties were very much able to
compete for power and challenge centrist
and right-wing parties at the same time
the Soviet Union as we now know finance
the Italian and to a lesser extent the
french communist parties while the unit
while the United States in Western
Europe was financing the Christian
Democrats the words Truman Doctrine
Donald's to camp doctrine the
establishment of the common form we all
know about that and we also know the
basic deeds the the Berlin crisis which
I think was particularly significant in
that it drew the line that the United
States would not tolerate further
encroachment of Soviet power further
moves by the Soviet Union into Western
Europe the United States did not
significantly challenged Soviet control
over Eastern Europe primarily because it
could not it made two attempts neither
of which has been studied enough I wish
that they they were there would be one
was in Poland and one was in Albania I
both terribly unsuccessful the Albanian
operation which was a joint one by the
CIA and and British intelligence that
failed because from the very beginning
it did not have a chance of course kim
Philby was between the Brits and the
Americans the intermediary and one can
imagine the one does not know as a fact
that he provided some information to the
Kremlin and through the Kremlin to D to
the the Albanians the Polish operation
was also a failure there there wasn't an
organization that did work after World
War Two WI
s and but pretty soon it was penetrated
by Polish special services who then
presented the Brits and the Americans in
London all sorts of pictures showing how
successful wis was and picked up all the
money which they then pocketed so by and
large there was no good way to undermine
Soviet of authority in Central and
Eastern Europe and by nineteen fifty two
or so the CIA all but stopped trying
some people left the agency realizing
that that the Communists were far better
at protecting their turf then the Nazis
had been in the Balkans such as Frank
Lindsey who was a deputy director of the
operational division and so all that the
u.s. could do was to talk I have
referred to this as NATO no action talk
only and this particularly started with
the Eisenhower administration talking
about liberation and roll back but there
was nothing behind that in terms of
actions and I'll come back to that to
describe it in just a moment until
nineteen fifty three i do believe as i
think most everybody else does that the
line was drawn the Cold War was frozen
in 1953 after the death of Stalin
something gradually became more complex
or to be more precise the cold war
became more complex this was no longer
confrontation alone there were other
dimensions or elements in the
relationship and somewhere I wrote many
many years ago that to other dimensions
began to be seen competition and
cooperation competition primarily in the
third world where money was being spent
by the Russians and then in 55 you will
remember Khrushchev and Bill Gannon made
their trips to India Indonesia Egypt etc
trying to revise and she indeed change
the old Stalinist
victim about either you're with us or
you're against us and so neutralism
non-alignment became more or less
accepted by the soviets even as we in
the united states were less sure whether
to to tolerate such moral ambiguity the
u.s. probably was more fundamentalist in
the first few years than the Soviet
Union that was pragmatic practical the
u.s. still looked at these countries of
the non-aligned countries as countries
that should stand up and be counted of
course with us also at the same time I
would stress that there were some very
few but some signs of cooperation the
third dimension of the relationship
especially in 1955 this was the time
when the Soviets withdrew from Austria
to the extraordinary surprise of the
world this was the year when Khrushchev
and bull ganyan went to ask Tito's
forgiveness and thus recognized national
roads to socialism this was the year
when there was a summit meeting between
Eisenhower and bull ganyan and who shop
so I and for that matter there was even
some discussion to be sure I didn't lead
anywhere but there was some discussion
in the Soviet Union about the future of
Germany so I would say that there that
one ought to look at the Cold War as
remaining primarily confrontational but
also the other two dimensions began to
be felt there was a lot of confusion
about this these three dimensions and of
course in Washington London and perhaps
especially in Bonn
not not so much understanding of what
was happening was the Soviet Union
engaged in another deceitful a broad
approach and should we not be vigilant
in the face of that and given the brutal
history of communism and of the Soviet
Union could you take another piece
offensive seriously that was a genuine
and and and quite understandable
reaction to the post Stalin opening by
the Soviet Union and of course behind
that were some serious reservations from
a US / centered perspective would they
taunt legitimize the Communist Party's
of Western Europe would a new they taunt
undermine other than ours anti-communist
position in a Germany were that where
things were not yet are very settled and
moreover should the West respond
strongly to Soviet overtures what would
that mean to the hopes of the East
Europeans or the east central Europeans
who wanted freedom and independence and
not some deal by the super powers over
their heads so for these reasons and I
think for a very important domestic
reason the US did not respond in a very
forthright fashion to the soviet soviet
approach which I characterized here very
briefly and I apologize to colleagues
who were would find this superficial the
additional reason that we seldom talked
about how to do with American domestic
conditions i think McCarthyism had a
major impact on the reluctance of the
Eisenhower administration to pick up the
Soviet offer and Biggie and begin
serious negotiations
to sum up this the point that I'm trying
to make here American skepticism
repeated than in Western Europe to a
lesser extent stemmed from a history of
communist deception and from confidence
that the division of Europe offered a
great deal of stability and should not
be changed very important in this
connection and very typical in this
connection is the response of the United
States to Chris jobs secret speech there
are several people here in the audience
who know so much more about this than I
do but I and if they don't agree I I am
sure that they will let me know
Khrushchev's secret speech should have
challenged the basic American approach
and overcome at least some of the
skepticism that the u.s. had about the
Cold War becoming a three-dimensional
rather than a one-dimensional affair it
did not respond that way how did the
u.s. respond to this extraordinary
statement in February 1956 well it spent
a good deal of time and money to get a
copy of it frantic search for a source
going to Yugoslavia first and couldn't
quite get a copy and then finally
getting one through via Poland but there
were two possibilities to treat the
content of the secret speech one was to
take post Stalin Russia postal in Soviet
Union seriously and get ready for
possible compromise solutions regarding
the future of Europe which is to say
consider the possibility over a period
of years if not a decade or two or
gradual disengagement
and gradual disarmament the second
possibility with respect to the future
of Europe was to use Khrushchev secret
speech and the facts of de-stalinization
only to further discredit communism I
call this the Dodger approach even even
Khrushchev has to admit I don't think
anybody used it that way in this country
but probably did the Dodger approach is
to quote selectively from the other
side's politicians and use that as
supportive of it what you want to do in
the first place after all you could ask
legitimately where was Khrushchev
himself when Stalin killed millions of
people how could we believe him now when
he says that Stalin did this this this
and that so this was the second one was
certainly the dominant us approach the
first one would have been to sit down
and talk negotiated probe and there was
a summit meeting in Geneva but not much
came of that and in u.s. foreign policy
at that time I identify three main
tendencies which explain or sceptical
approach one is the what might be called
the fundamentalist essentialists like
Secretary of State dollars who believed
I used the word essential is because he
believed that the essence of communism
is the problem that must change rather
than tactics or even strategies before
the US could seriously deal with the
Soviet Union I believe this was a
dominant approach perhaps the dominant
then there was a real politic approach
within the Eisenhower administration
exemplified by Vice President Richard
Nixon who essentially believed the worse
the better the real
a cold warrior but not not an idea
ideological cold warrior so much he said
in july 1956 at a secret meeting of the
National Security Council that it would
not be an unmixed evil if Soviet forces
were to enter Central and Eastern Europe
and crush any resistance to come in his
room it would not be an unmixed evil
well you can understand why he said that
he said that because then then the
Soviets would be seen for what they are
interventionists cruel brutal and in the
psychological warfare that Nixon favored
we would have another a trump card as it
were in our hands there was a third
approach and that i think was
Eisenhower's and he was a chairman of
the board he did not early enough
discredit McCarthyism which I believe
was a major mistake he was cautious he
was prudent he was willing to talk with
the Russians he had reservations about
Dallas's fundamentalist approach but in
the end he was unable to impose his will
on an administration that I did not see
things quite his way now underneath it
all though when you add up these
tendencies the United States choice the
real choice that the u.s. may it had to
do with a desire for victory over
communism confrontation and not
competition or cooperation certainly
comfort that were confrontation was seen
as the best way to undermine communist
rule because otherwise the systems the
communist systems would have stayed
perhaps in a modified way perhaps one or
two could have escaped partially or or
from from Soviet control but the idea of
just weakening communist rule did not
seem to appeal to the Eisenhower
administration perhaps it had to do more
with domestic affairs them with with
foreign affairs more with ideological
orientation more with fundamentalism i
am not sure i don't really know enough
to say but it's clear that the choice
between trying to undermine communism
and weakening communism that choice was
made this brings me to the Hungarian
Revolution for the
post talent date on that never got off
the ground died on the streets of
Budapest it was probably a once in
history opportunity in 1953 at the time
of the East Berlin riots there was no
chance for the East Berliners to get
away from Soviet control partly because
Germany's importance of course was so
huge but partly because the Soviet
leadership was not yet ready to consider
rational alternatives later on once the
Gary Powers affair happened and one
Sputnik already in 1957 threatened the
daylight out of the United States surely
there was no realistic opportunity for
us to consider making deals with the
Russians in nineteen sixty eight there
was no chance for the very moderate and
limited goals of Czechoslovakia to get
away from the Soviets for the obvious
reason the Brezhnev regime was well
established in its in its semi Stalinist
fashion 1956 was different 1956 55 and
56 represented years of opportunity for
deal-making in the indie in east-west
relations but it didn't happen this is
why hungry could not obtain some of the
limited goals all of it could never have
happened but some of it in my judgment
could have happened I do believe that
the basic story of the hungarian
revolution is accurate today to after
after seeing all the archives and not
much more is likely to emerge for
decades to come certainly that's the
message I got in in Moscow this week
it's a story of David and Goliath that a
small country could not get away from an
imperialist power
but then this in the Soviet archives
opened and particularly in the mid-1990s
the so-called Mullen notes have surfaced
that have been brilliantly analyzed by
mark kramer who is here and and by anna
Shriner the the head of the 1956
institute in hungary i should add that
the Russian analysts or scholars have
not done so where they have produced the
data the documents but but there is
little or no analysis that one can rely
on so we have it in English and we have
it in Hungarian what the Molly notes
show sketchy as they are is that there
were deep divisions in the Soviet
president during the time of the
hungarian revolution that there was a
good deal of hesitation that they were
shifting coalition's between what Ryan
Joyner caused the Liberals led by McCoy
jaan and usually supported by Khrushchev
and the others usually led by Molotov
and Voroshilov but these were shifting
coalition's and and very difficult to
pinpoint real factions I'm sure we will
hear more about this tomorrow morning
this is what has prompted me to conclude
in in my new book failed illusions that
a Soviet intervention on November for
1956 was not inevitable I've already
given you the reasons the general
reasons for that austria openings 20th
party congress etc in other words the
post Soviet leaders were more open to
change in the rigid to camp division of
the world including Europe then we
assumed at that time and that's being
assumed by many people still today but
there were more importantly specific
reasons during the crisis
that suggests to me conclusively that
the Soviet leaders were considering
other options they were not trigger
happy at all Khrushchev and especially
Mike McEwen were deeply concealing
committed to the processes of distal
anization and they seem to have
understood very well that an
intervention in Hungary would give their
opponents in the Soviet Union a stronger
hand who could point to them and say you
see this is what you brought about and
this is what they wanted to avoid when
they considered giving him r annoyed and
his government a chance to put hungary
in order by what they meant by that is a
subject of debate surely that did not
mean hungry being able to join nato
surely it didn't mean that both the
Soviet troops would leave and the Warsaw
Pact would seem would would would not be
run out of not apply to her to hungry
but some compromise solutions were in
the air and we're cautiously being
considered
on October thirtieth in particular
without going through the debates of the
recorded in the molly notes up to that
point that is the seventh day of the
revolution the Soviet Presidium
unanimously voted in great secret of
course against military intervention
they preferred a political solution a
decision however that they reverse the
very next day on the thirty-first the
question is why then did they decide not
to intervene on the 30th and why they
decided to intervene on the 31st and
that's something that we have to in in
large part speculate about because there
is no cable there is no report from
Budapest to buy by McCoy on Siuslaw
board or the Ambassador on drop off or
KGB GRU cables that would clearly tell
us why they changed their mind we do
have first jobs explanation to Tito on
November third and we do have of course
both Christians and my crayons memoirs
putting it all together which is not
conclusive but i think it is decisive is
the fact that they believe that this
colonization was on the line a second
one was the expectation that in
greenwich who after all in the 1930s was
an NKVD agent and who was in after world
war two head of the administrative
department which of the communist party
of hungry and as such in supervising the
special services in the military that
employed will save socialism for the
soviet union and over time political and
economic methods by the soviet union
will keep hungry in the Soviet camp and
I think another factor against military
intervention was the fear that still
that day that they might have to
intervene in Poland and if they if they
would have to do that they they were
smart enough to know that they might not
be able to do it effectively in both
places
these are good arguments unfortunately
they were in operative in the famous
words of the Nixon White House one day
later what happened why was it reversed
well it may well be somebody after one
of my lectures suggested this and I find
it quite possible though not not all
that telling is that who shot changed
his mind that he had he slept on the
issue and then he realized as he said
it's in the Mullen notes that our party
would not understand the loss of both
Egypt and Hungary very possible he did
he does say he didn't sleep that night
maybe we do know that he argued with my
crayon whoo-hoo all the way opposed the
decision what else happened though you
know I kept searching what else happened
on the 30th that would have made such a
big difference and here i think the
hungarians themselves had some
responsibility there was there were
significant atrocities against against
the communists and and special services
let me members of the special services
that day some 20 of them were on
lamppost it was particularly ugly I
happen I was there I saw that as a young
man and it was unfortunate because some
of those young folks wearing the uniform
of the hated aval actually were drafted
so they had no choice but being there
doesn't mean that they ever tortured
anybody or harmed anybody that was their
assignment instead of being you know
border guards they were in the special
services so did that news though reach
Moscow well one has to assume that such
a major event after all they were afraid
at the Soviet embassy a few blocks away
maybe two kilometres away they were
afraid that their own security as
somebody just told me in Moscow who was
there they were concerned about their
own security at the Embassy so it's only
logical to assume that it got there
another thing
we know that that day the Hungarian
virus was spreading it was spreading to
Ukraine he was spreading to Transylvania
especially and so all of this work plus
possibly some influence or some
conversations by the Chinese though I
don't think Khrushchev decided this
matter as in the end he did because the
Chinese did so the opportunity provided
by Suez you know a variety of things i
do not know exactly what mattered and
how much but clearly in one day they
reverse the decision and and started to
crush the hungarian revolution the last
question that i want to raise here is
what did the Hungarians and Americans do
that made the success of the Hungarian
revolt impossible well I think the
answer to both is that both the
Americans and the Hungarians rejected
have solutions in using a football idiom
that i have used now many times they
went for a touchdown instead of trying
to carry the ball for four or five yards
at a time they believe that that they
did not believe that something was
better than nothing they over the
revolutionaries overestimated their
power they believe that their cause was
just which I also believe that it was
and they thought that that was the only
thing that really mattered and they did
not consider the Soviet response or
acted despite it I don't blame them
their age was under 20 everage age was
25 and many of them were only teenagers
and I one does not expect
revolutionaries coming from a romantic
political culture to consider
geopolitical realities and act
accordingly that would be absurd but I
don't think it is absurd to expect
from their leaders and there is no
evidence that even once in renoise who
did talk to them would call in the
revolutionary some groups many of whom
by the way were socialists in their
orientation most of them were and said
look you know this is where we are this
is where the Soviet Union is they have
so many tanks and soldiers we're weak
let's work out a solution some of what
you want semi independence semi freedom
we can get we cannot get it all this was
not done and I think major chance was
missed what about the United States well
I already described American policy as
as maximalist working for the defeat of
communism and not for weakening it by
nineteen sixty or so after Brzezinski
and Griffith published their piece in
foreign affairs and the Kennedy
administration came in major changes
took place and and the idea was to
weaken the Communist hold over Eastern
Europe rather than to undermine it in
any basic kind of way but at that time
it was through radio free europe
primarily that the United States
encouraged the Hungarian revolutionaries
to pursue maximal is goals and I
the idea that the Cold War was no longer
just confrontation but it was more
complex with the addition of two other
dimensions simply did not carry weight
in Munich the reason for that should be
understood however it's nothing sinister
about this it's very clear that station
was established in order to undermine
communism and up as part of a
psychological warfare what else could
they have done they had to do what they
were set out to do until stronger orders
came from Washington on by 1960-61 that
this station must change its profile
aside from rfv however the United States
did nothing nothing to help assist the
Hungarians I did one of the features of
my book is is that I had access to the
CIA's operational files for the first
time and by the way you can read that
the most important parts are now on the
web was put on the on the web by the
National Security Archive I just gave it
to them and so I think yesterday or day
before yesterday about a hundred pages
with some deletions the usual deletions
that the agency does what is still very
interesting and I I'd urge you to read
it to check my own conclusions well here
are some of the features of what the CIA
did not do from nineteen 48 to 52 the
agency and its predecessor the OPC
conducted no covert action operations in
Hungary in 1952 the CIA had no regularly
reporting resident agents inside hungry
while it's it's attempted cross so
called cross-border missions either
failed or had to be aborted
from 53 to 56 the CIA had one agent in
Hungary who was disguised at the US
legation as a political officer and his
efforts to obtain and maintain contact
with reporting sources were
quote-unquote unsuccessful this one
agent who is alive and lives in Virginia
by the way in an old-age home was
directed during the revolution not to
get involved in operations he was told
to do such supporting tasks as I'm not
making this up quote purchasing stamps
and stationery mailing letters and
generally helping to look after matters
of security and code during the
revolution this man was the only
Hungarian speaking official at the
legation he spent his time opening and
closing the legations door and accepting
petitions that Hungarians brought their
petitions to you know plead with the US
about getting some help or another it
put it put it briefly was a doorman in
nearby countries where the CIA did have
agents it didn't have a single Hungarian
speaking agent during the revolution as
in a french comedy by moliere the CIA
was looking please look up on the web my
evidence they were looking for some
agent who was on vacation somewhere but
the CIA personnel records did not show
where the hell this character was and so
they couldn't find him and bring him
back this contrary to many reports many
reports you know critical of the of the
CIA the CIA did not have a fighting unit
trained and ready to enter hungry in
1956 such a unit of about eight to ten
Hungarian exiles nothing very big to be
sure these were right wingers
who left Hungary in 44 40 and 45 that
unit was disbanded in late nineteen
fifty-two keep in mind that the CIA
transferred its interest from Eastern
Europe to the Far Far East because of
Korea at about at about that time during
the revolt the White House forbade any
agent to enter hungry and but if even if
permission had been granted to transfer
arms or ammunition to the insurgents
which was forbidden by CIA headquarters
and by President Eisenhower such a
transfer could not have taken place
incredibly and I'm not making this up
either the CIA misplaced the record of
where in Western Europe it was hiding
weapons and ammunition though eventually
they were found you asked when they were
found they were found in the first week
of December 1956 one month after the
Kremlin had crushed the revolution so
the US did nothing there were no
diplomatic moves no use of possible
economic means intelligence as I just
described was not there it did have
broadcast that were many broadcasts
certainly not all but many broadcasts
pushed the Hungarians towards towards a
final victory let me just conclude here
by by relating to two stories one is
about our Fe after the revolt in
February 1957 there was a staff meeting
a workshop discussing the lessons for
Radio Free Europe there a staff member
as the William E Griffith many of you
remember bill Griffith the radios
political advisor about what he would do
differently in case another revolt was
to occur in the region the staffer
wanted to know would we openly tell that
there was no hope Griffiths answer quote
not openly only indirectly we would let
it be known in our new news and
commentary programs and finally i'm not
sure i have that quote here hope i do
you may say well god he is now smart
aleck 50 years later he finds it all and
reinterprets everything that may be the
case but let me also say that there were
some wise people at that time who
understood that accomplishing less is
more and advised the US government to be
prudent and and seek less walter
Lippmann wrote in The Washington Post
and Times Herald on october 26 less than
three days into the revolt very wisely
very wisely the following and i quote in
the interest of peace and freedom
freedom from both despotism and anarchy
we must hope that for a time not forever
but for a time the uprising in the
satellite orbit will be stabilized at
tito ism no American politicians in the
climate of the cold war abroad and
McCarthyism at home could have accepted
that conclusion I believe this is the
story of 1956 in a cold war context and
this is the story of my book as well
thank you very much and I don't want to
have a major break
I hope you'll forgive me because the the
reason for the next longer period that
we spend for the next panel is again to
leave enough discussion also after the
presentations of the panelists so are
there any questions yes please and yes I
think that brilliant presentation that I
find a big competition in professor Gary
mentioned how kim Philby a communist
agent compromise operations and several
countries at the same time the attacks
Senator McCarthy for bringing out at in
our own government when we were in
tackiness communism we had official tie
officials about of American government
who would not state categorically that
they were not communist third party
members I think that's a serious and
well professor Katya has already taken
some notes I think if you would like to
ask your question
US policy works Hungary was maximized
but didn't exist
and remember this
the US Coast drivers same time as
possible and try to explain living dolls
focus
possibly have communist party
driven and
did something to support more energy to
consolidate gave a false love an origami
models of how to explain it such really
different or opposite life policies
exactly the same
thank you yes perhaps one last question
and then I hand over to Professor County
Oh
don't
that
but they didn't think
okay thank you well we had one
comparative question and then the
question about kim Philby so professor
got here let me go back where it was a
simple answer to your question about
Brzezinski article not not 56 57 that
was reprinted Brzezinski writes a blurb
on the back of my book and this I had an
opportunity many times to discuss my
book with him including a time when I
stopped writing because i was so full of
my mind was troubled about a variety of
issues taking in grenada off the
pedestal and so on and so forth and he
encouraged me to go on he'd i would say
it is fair to come to pass on the
information that he shares my view about
the emptiness of the u.s. of the u.s.
foreign policy towards Eastern Europe at
that time I I don't want to go into
further details let him speak for
himself he certainly rights enough and
talks enough to to to do that but he has
no disagreement with me on that issue
okay now with respect to were going
backwards Pavel that's a very important
point of difference with Poland and i
would i would explain it in terms of
personalities the main thing was that
Imre Nagy was never accepted by the
united states is not just our fe at all
but the United States somehow found him
to be less of a reformer then then he
actually was Illinois was a very
effective reform communist in 53 55 and
yet
either in the embassy reports or
whatever I have found I have found
nothing positive about him this may be
and now this is a guess on my part miss
may be due to the fact that he was a
muscovite that he had spent the interwar
period or at least the 1930s there the
US government did not know that he was
an NKVD agent to the best of my
knowledge and I think I probably would
have seen that in the in the material I
was given so but gloom ulka was
different he was that he was a
nationalist so I think that one
difference was the difference between
umbra annoyed at the u.s. mistrusted and
go moco whom was a communist but a one
that clearly was seen by American
officials as another Tito a second
difference was the role of Cardinal
Wyszynski who supported go mocha and you
know the appeal of the Polish Catholic
Church in Washington and for that matter
here in New York was quite considerable
and the third was the the skill with
which he on Novak led the Polish desk of
Radio Free Europe I am sure there were
many other reasons as well but the fact
remained that that you are quite right
there was a different approach to
Hungary and a different approach to
Poland and one would wish in retrospect
that the same approach that they apply
to Poland would have been used towards
hungry but the fact of the matter that I
think for the reasons I just mentioned
this was not the case now as for kim
Philby I did not say that he betrayed
other see I don't know what secrets he
really betrayed and I am not even sure
about the Albanian thing he was the
intermediary between nothing to do with
Portland the Polish w is as far as I
know filthy had nothing to do with that
he did
but see I didn't know that thank you
what haha well I didn't know that thank
you okay so he was involved in in both
cases but somebody who knows more about
these things than I do said that the use
and I'm not an expert on intelligence
that Philby had only so many
opportunities to report his findings and
that the Soviet Union his Soviet bosses
would did not want him to spend his time
on explaining or passing on him detailed
information about Albania they were much
more interested in you know strategic
weapons and that sort of thing well be
that as it may I do not know whether and
how much he betrayed and I stand
corrected by your perspective that he
was active on Poland as well but the
fact of the matter is that the special
services of both Albania and especially
Poland were very very effective and so
you didn't have to have a field day to
line up I know much more about the
Albanian operation to line up the
Albanian operation now I would probably
not agree with the implication of what
you're saying that a few American
Americans in Hollywood that McCarthy was
after made some significant difference
in how the Cold War was played
okay well we can talk about those those
those in the State Department and I know
I know their stories reasonably well
probably not as well as you do I'm very
critical as I take it you might not be
of McCarthy violating American civil
rights during an era of Red Scare and
also of going after people who were not
involved or involved in a minor way most
of the people that he listed did not
exist some did and they should have been
treated by the FBI in a in a very strict
way and and excluded from the US
government but the spirit of McCarthyism
I think penetrated American society and
did not allow American politicians to
offer alternatives to what we were doing
at that time that is my great regret
that it's in a there was one thought and
only a walter Lippmann could say
something else but people who wanted to
get elected look the demo Adlai
Stevenson and the Democratic party
platform in 1956 went further than the
Republicans in advocating the liberation
and rollback of Soviet power from
Eastern Europe so you know and at that
climate I think reinforced by
McCarthyism was most unfortunate it's by
the way I I have declined in my book and
in my talks I will make an exception now
to refer to anything contemporary but
the I am probably shouldn't be saying
this but I do find some similarity here
between the way the war in Iraq started
and Democrats supported it and the way
in the 1950s the eyes now
administration did not have any
opposition to this nonsense called
liberation and roll back well thank you
very much again we already had quite a
number of points which I'm sure will be
part of our subsequent discussions also
but before I thank professor karti again
I had some second thoughts I think it
would be very cruel if I just asked you
to stay here now and not to have a
five-minute break at least so that you
can get yourselves a coffee but before I
dismiss you could I just briefly
introduce the chair of the next panel
professor Nippon she who is it was over
there who is at the professor of Slovak
literature at Barnard College also to
the director of the Harriman Institute
and we have cooperated closely and
therefore I think she is also as a
Russian 'used the ideal person to chair
this meeting and she will of course
introduce the panelists once we restart
so five minutes get yourselves a coffee
thank you very much again professor
Gotti